pakistan will send more aid to ukraine
to help with the humanitarian crisis in
a phone call on tuesday pakistani prime
minister and ukraine's president agreed
on the urgent need for a ceasefire and a
resolution to the conflict through
diplomacy but as western pressure mounts
against the russian invasion of ukraine
south asia's political dynamics are
changing at the u.n general assembly 35
countries abstained from voting against
russia including bangladesh india and
sri lanka
hours before russia attacked ukraine
prime minister imran khan was in moscow
a visit scheduled months in advance
attracted both criticism and praise from
opponents and supporters
pakistan wants to enhance bilateral ties
including building a pipeline to import
russian gas while progress on that
remains slow president vladimir putin
has signed a few other deals
we are expanding our relationships and
it's always going to be a balancing act
i mean you can china and america have
their differences with each other but
they trade so intensely with each other
the quantums are absolutely
mind-boggling pakistan wants a bigger
financial diplomatic and strategic space
in the region but it also has a delicate
balancing act between russia and western
powers as it needs both regional
relevance and economic partnerships
in recent weeks the prime minister
lashed out at eu diplomats asking for
public condemnation of russia
i asked these eu ambassadors if they
wrote a similar letter to india our
country's economy lost 100 billion
dollars i ask did you appreciate or
acknowledge us are we your slaves that
whatever you order we must comply
for pakistan the recent u.s pull out
from afghanistan and china's economic
diplomacy means its policies are no
longer based on what the u.s prefers
pakistan has felt a lot of pressure from
the western countries vis-a-vis the u.n
security council so having a permanent
member of the u.n security council
batting for pakistan at the uran
security council is great the western
countries themselves are choosing to
move away from pakistan nobody asked
president biden to not call the
pakistani leadership nobody forced
western countries to lean towards india
but government leaders here say it's not
a pivot from old alliances and relations
cannot be mutually exclusive they want
both ties with russia and a diplomatic
solution to the war in ukraine osama bin
laden jazeera islamabad